早上
下車
快點
慢點
再來
再加完再加完
字幕提供
音樂蠻好聽的
喔這個
呃感冒中啊
齁所以有點小聲喔
這樣子來這樣子來
這樣我大聲一點
喔因為這個感冒中啊
聲音比較小一點
這樣子
這樣我聽到
有沒有聽到
這樣又比較大聲了吧
麥克風比較近了
我把這個開大一點
有聽到聲音就好
小哥好沙啞
之前更慘
好不好
前天去中南部上課
一邊咳一邊
一邊那個
那個
一邊咳一邊上
好
欸對呀
那個
有個學員
也是好朋友啊
也是我們常出國的團員最近呢在我家旁邊我家附近在附近 開了一間火鍋店開了一間火鍋店喔各位呢你去那邊
吃火鍋呢
報我的名字
就送你肉盤或者是海鮮啦
送肉盤或海鮮
那以後呢我們才打算做一個東西啊
我覺得蠻有趣的
各位看一下喔
這邊呢有
這個螢幕是80...好像85吋吧
那我們之後呢我們還打算怎麼樣
等一下我發個限動一下
我們之後呢還打算把它
誒...發個貼文好了
之後呢...它那邊還有兩個螢幕啊
那兩個螢幕呢我們打算來放那個
全方位加當充神器
那我們打算說誒看能不能
這個盤中啊
拉去那邊看盤
還有這種想法
就是這個放這個
呃當沖神器
跟全方位
等一下我看一下
我來看一下我的那個圖片
我看我的圖片
我找一下
找一下那個
放全方位的照片
照片
欸我覺得假如可以放全方位齁
這蠻有意思的
找到了
好
我們先發個文齁
我們先發在那個
發在FB好了
想說餐廳
邊吃飯邊看
邊...欸...欸...
早上
看兩個
我發文了
喝著咖啡看兩個85吋的螢幕
這樣子的看盤地方可以嗎
好
等一下
我發文了
我發文了我們來看一下
給各位看那個實際的狀況
實際狀況這樣子
哈哈
喔這邊呢 這個
贊助兩個螢幕
喔那這兩個螢幕呢就可以一邊看全方位監控喔一邊看那個當充神器喔然後這邊是那個桌上當然可以放筆電嘛對不對看完筆電
這個看完
早上
8點半到11點半可以看盤
那11點半以後呢
11點半到1點半可以吃火鍋
那8點半到11點半呢
那個飲料喝到飽
飲料喝到飽
你覺得這樣
這樣如何
8點半到11點半
全發位聲音高頻不太好
還好啦
各位各位你覺得這樣好不好
這樣好不好
這盤中這樣子你看這螢幕多大啊
超大超滿是這個座位有90個你知道嗎
座位有90個
還蠻好玩的
然後來來
唉唷這個立馬詐騙來留言
這個
來這邊看盤你用
那跟VIP看板式不一樣
VIP看板式你看的螢幕都很小
然後這螢幕你看 各位看這螢幕超大
對不對 超大
齁 然後呢 欸我明天我們的全方位會改成20分
欸 那個以前是5分鐘5點有聲音
後來發現了 現在台股36000點了
所以呢 它一直都有聲音
齁 所以覺得這樣子太吵了
現在改成5分鐘20點
所以明天呢 各位打開全方位齁
它的聲音會改變齁
我們以前是這個5分鐘5點有聲音
然後呢把它改一改之後發現
欸這個改成50點都沒聲音
今天50點好像就ㄉㄧㄥ一下
那之後呢會改成5分鐘20點
那各位呢我們再看一下那個聲音的頻率啦
叫做太常出現也不好
太少出現也...
欸
太常出現不好
太少出現也不好
好
處置神器看手機就好了啦
處置神器這個就一個通知而已
齁 那處置神器真的很好用齁
我昨天呢 我做了一個
這個配齁
我做了錦碩猩猩配
齁 那我在那個高雄廠的上課有特別提到齁
高雄廠上課我有提齁 各位有在高雄上課的
齁 這個認真點聽課應該有聽得到
我有講齁 我有講齁
剛好上課呢 我有講說那個 你要可以做
星星跟錦碩
喔 剛剛說 我是跟玄說 我會做星星跟錦碩啦
喔 會做星星跟錦碩喔 那為什麼做星星跟錦碩 因為星星要被關了喔以我在昨天呢 我就是空了星星買緊碩昨天空了星星買緊碩
一開始建倉之後呢 欸還小賠一點
還小賠喔 那後面
今天整個出來之後 今天整個是
這個整個組合是大蒜啦
我昨天是空星星 然後買緊碩
各位你看一下
空星星嘛 為什麼空星星呢
因為
因為他被關了嘛 對
然後買景碩
啊買景碩,景碩昨天那個點位蠻漂亮的
景碩的點位是回到上升月前
那今天景碩是漲的啦
來來來,各位看一下
今天景碩,欸,漲嗎?
我覺得盤中才漲蠻多的
來,我看一下今天啦
今天盤中漲蠻多的,盤中有曾經漲到386塊
盤中漲蠻多的,然後今天星星是跌的比較多
喔所以呢我們是空心心埋頸碎
然後這整個組合呢就賺錢
喔這整個組合賺錢
你看看
喔
喔20點踏觸發34喔感覺好像
也
也也也不多
吃個火鍋吃4個半小時沒有啦
你吃火鍋吃個大概兩個小時
中前面8點半到11點半
8點半就開始準備看試戳嘛
齁 然後呢 各位呢 螢幕放上去
你就至少可以看這個東西啊 我覺得還蠻不錯的啊
你至少可以看一個
看個這個正價差比 逆價差比嘛 對不對
呦 正價差比 沒跑出來
齁 至少盤中可以看個正價差比 逆價差比
那我可以看一下 這個 你看喔 這邊中紅星星齁
正價差比 逆價差比 這個在明天很好用啦 齁 明天有
明天有那個
結算嘛
所以明天結算我們都是
靠這個來做套利的齁
明天這個可以做一個蠻好的套利
蠻好的套利
連早餐一起吃齁
早餐
你自己帶進來啊
我們裡面提供咖啡啊對不對
咖啡豆還蠻不錯的齁
咖啡機也很貴
咖啡豆蠻不錯的
在裡面喝咖啡就好了
喝咖啡
我用幾吋
我用16吋
喔
火鍋開可能吃到12點
順便檢討監
你就順便在裡面吃火鍋啊
阿其實我覺得那火鍋
那個他的
青菜吃到飽嘛對不對
所以你在裡面
這個我覺得光吃青菜都很好阿
光吃青菜都很好阿
現在
現在菜還不算貴齁
以後菜貴的時候
青菜吃到飽真的非常划算
我今天吃火鍋我覺得他的牛肉蠻讚的
他牛肉
裡面有和牛 和牛超好吃
很有很好吃喔
好 儲物神器很好用喔 對
儲物神器其實那個找
不管是找空點找買點
都真的很好用
那明天套利
套利假如明天有
例如說有中紅這個可以套
套死他明天有這種
套利一定是狂賺好不好
那這個很簡單嘛這就是空奇窩
買鮮窩然後尾盤補掉就好了
尾盤補掉就好了
那明天最適合做為什麼
你尾盤都可以補掉
然後你現貨你的成本只有0.15%
你的現貨成本只有0.15%
然後再加一點點手續費
大概月末是0.23%
就一般人打三折
你的成本大概是0.23%
那像這邊有0.66%以上的齁
這個有機會套都可以套
齁 有機會套都可以套
來做這個套利
齁 那這個其實我覺得套利可以做
然後我們最近教的處置戰法
也真的很好用
因為處置戰法我最推崇的是雙刀
喔這個做雙刀真的很好
那在昨天有個很完美的點就是
新興配景說
那今天呢我有做一刀
那各位呢你明天看看嘛
看看明天的狀況
我今天有做高麗配雙紅
我做的是高麗配雙紅
我今天高麗也黑黑黑黑有賺到
除了高麗黑黑有賺到以外
我還有我今天是買雙紅
我今天是高麗配雙紅
啊這兩個都是屬於散熱的
各位你看一下高麗長這樣 雙紅長這樣
高麗長這樣 雙紅長這樣
我是空高麗買雙紅
這個都跟各位講了 也沒差啦
就是做高麗雙紅配
用台新會不會補掉
會 各位最近台新跟原副合併啊
最近台新跟原副合併
台新的系統各位小心點啦
因為合併呢 剛合併的時候問題很多啊
聽說今天錯了一億的錯帳啊
做一億的作帳我還想補不掉就完蛋了呵呵呵明天要開全方位直播嗎欸那個欸以後這個
我們那個我們是用這個餐廳呢
麻煩這家餐廳幫我們來做一個
全方位跟當中神器的那個示範店
各位呢假如看不懂的
你可以去這餐廳裡面看
付點些許的那個餐飲費
飲費 咖啡要錢嘛 對不對
電要錢嘛 冷氣要錢嘛
所以當然要付點錢 對不對
這個學員開店總是
總是要這個 要點營收的嘛
那個錢不貴啦 比你去做星巴克
還便宜啦 還便宜
你去星巴克隨便點也不少錢 對不對
那至少星巴克你點一杯咖啡
你再續杯就要錢了
我們吃讓你喝到飽
所以我覺得還不錯啊
那你假如去券商的VIP室
VIP室小小間嘛
這個有的螢幕小小的
這個你去哪邊可以看那種有兩個85吋的螢幕
你要看到兩個85吋螢幕看不見啦
85吋螢幕呢
欸哪有對不對
所以以後可以在這邊看盤
那這個位置90個
90個還不錯啊
這個
欸 我沒辦法一早就去啦 因為我在家裡打單比較順
喔 那假如這個 中間比較閒了 中間可以過去看看
喔 中間可以過去看看
喔 這個 看這個 我覺得蠻有意思的啦
喔 就是有個地方可以看盤 喔
有個地方可以看盤 啊可以聊天 同好可以聊天啦
我覺得同好聊天是件有趣的事
像我們現在盤中 其實都會開那個
Discord嘛 就是幾個學員在盤中這樣聊天
那我們除了聊天以外呢 我們
我們就買的標的喔 買的標的有時候買的標的蠻類似的
VIP是不是網路會比較快
欸這個網路可能沒那麼快 各位你可能要帶你去
欸那個 因為那邊現在在做捷運
那邊現在在做捷運喔 所以
所以
所以他的網路目前還沒辦法弄很快
因為捷運他沒辦法讓他重新拉線
那假如可以拉線的話當然是很好啊
那給各位看一下目前的道路的狀況道路狀況長這樣他在渣渣打的對面就這樣欸欸在在在渣打的對面在這裡 在這一塊這一塊
喔 啊最近最近一直在
呃 你從外表看不是長這樣子啦
反正就在這一間
喔 然後這是借收入啦
喔 那最近在做捷運啦
所以這邊會比較亂一點
那車子可能就要停在
附近喔 這邊會有停車場
喔 那你可以可以過來
喔 然後
呃
你裡面設備是很新啊
這叫槽頂
槽頂啊 我也在上面寫
欸 我今天有趣喔 我打個卡
各位呢
打卡
這邊 這裡啊
我今天要打個卡
我覺得蠻好玩的
朝向紅盤看指標
對不對 今天大盤創新高嘛
對不對
頂中沸騰熱氣燒
1點半以後跑去吃火鍋
火熱行情擋擋標
最近大盤太標了啊
什麼都還標
這個
漲停板可以100多檔對不對
現在這個大盤非常的妖啊
大盤非常的妖
大盤集妖
然後呢
新創高點大盤奧
先從K點利潤到
美鑽交同慶祝
味道甘甜聖鐵報
報我的名字呢
欸 報小哥粉絲送肉盤或海鮮
喔 報小哥粉絲送肉盤或海鮮
五星討平送標的
可以你叫老闆送你
呃 老闆也會那個
老闆也有研究股票
喔 這 這 這不是VIP室啊
這是在一個
他們沒有VIP室啊 他們沒有包廂啦
目前沒有做包廂
反正這是一個很大的空間
很大的空間
喔 很大空間 就這樣
喔 各位
各位 我是覺得
蠻有意思的 蠻有趣的
好 那我們今天聊一下
這個神秘分點建倉清單
神秘分點建倉清單 那我們就要想到一堂股票啦
那這堂股票
這個之前很多學員問的啦
就是我們之前有提過的股票叫經濟
很多學員問 啊小哥這堂股票
那個到底行不行啊
那個關鍵分點到底買了到底怎麼樣
看一下
那之前呢 有在這裡啊
這個元大北投 元大北投買很多嘛買完之後呢 我們一度以為他要噴的但是還是把他洗到脫皮那最近怎麼樣 最近就真的噴出去了最近噴出去 元大北投開始順勢獲利了結一些
欸 等一下 有人要問火鍋
我跟各位講 火鍋很好吃 那那個肉很好吃
為什麼肉很好吃呢
因為那個肉齁 有詳細去挑鍋的
然後我們再去挑的過程中才知道齁
有些比較大的公司啊
我們當然不能講哪一家啦
有些比較大的 名氣比較大的公司喔
他們都不挑肉的
就吃名氣
你吃肉就知道了 反正你去巷吃就知道了
你就知道那實際那肉吃起來口感不一樣
那個我們已經吃過很多次了
我常去吃啦
常去吃 肉真的是不錯
肉的品質很好
裡面花枝漿也很好吃
各位有興趣可以去吃
好 然後這個
經濟是這樣
經濟呢就是
他的
關鍵先買
然後呢
他的另外大股東再買
另外大股東就是元大管錢
那元大管錢呢
他在庫長股實施完之後
他就進來買
然後那時候這個
欸 我們還透過
就是有聽到這個消息啦
那時有聽到 就聽說
那個元大管錢買的股票
不大會賠啦
不大會賠
他在低檔買了一堆經濟 你從現在看就知道
他們當然沒有賠
他們賺翻了 各位我們來看360天
元大北投賺了1億4
元大管錢賺了3億1億
3億1億4
各位看到沒有 這是我們之前一直提的股票
我們不只提啊
我們那個
我們這群人
曾經
同時持有
那個期貨加現貨
加一加也破千張
同時持有也超過千張
好啦好啦 這不是重點
因為他已經過了 他已經噴了
他已經噴了
現在跟你講呢
我是覺得他假如有機會進處置的話
拉回是個非常非常好的買點
有機會進處置的話
那他有機會進處置
他有機會進處置
因為他已經連續兩天
第一款了
所以呢
他有機會進儲資
這個在儲資神器裡面有
儲資神器裡面就有寫
經濟明天聽牌的條件
唉唷
聽牌條件還蠻簡單的
蠻簡單的
所以明天呢
我們期待經濟
那個
期待經濟被關
好不好
假設經濟有被關的話
回檔是個很好的買點
再跟各位講一次喔
假設經濟有悖觀的話
回檔是個很好很好的買點
經濟是這樣子
好 那經濟已經過去了
各位呢 未來怎麼辦呢
未來呢 我們就要去找那個
目前喔
他還在大買中
而且呢 買的量呢 又非常非常大
那我買的量又很大
然後呢 至少配息也不錯 之前我們也說
啊經濟配息
很好啊 各位你
你不買
你不賺價差 至少賺配息嘛 各位你看一下 7.5 7.4
5.2對不對
喔 那今年4.8
啊你80塊配5塊 對不對 那時候有人問啊 80塊怎麼辦
80塊配5塊有什麼不好喔 對 80塊配5塊
好說也是有6%多嘛對不對
我說6%多也很好啊
對 6%多也很好對不對
啊現在也沒有了現在
現在142塊了
現在整個殖利率暴低了
剩下3.6%
啊這個有回檔
殖利率還會拉上去
啊經濟實音原件有缺貨好不好
反正各位只要有個缺
只要有個缺字
缺制 股價就噴了
那這個打底打那麼久了
所以在跟各位講
行情不只這樣
那你沒上車的 你也不要上車了
要被關了嘛
假如有機會 被關回檔
你再上車
被關回檔就是個好的上車點
好 經濟已經過去了
不是已經過去了 未來有機會啦
當然叫你不要追高
明天早上更不要追喔
你不要今天聽到我講的
明天早上
這個那個一早就去買 千萬不要為什麼麼因為經濟明天只要在那個跟各位講
經濟明天只要跌4%以內
跌4%以內喔
漲會被關
平板也會被關
跌4%以內也會被關
所以呢經濟明天不要再追了
有賣
手裡有貨
想賣的都可以賣
因為明天會被關
關了有機會拉回的話
你再買回來
想買再買回來啦
想買再買回來
好
那這是經濟啦
這個是免費的直播
我也沒有特別的
叫你幹嘛
我不是通過老師
這一切你就做模擬交易就好了
好
那
現在跟你講的是
那有沒有另外一檔
目前呢
在低基期
就是位置很低喔
有多低喔
比疫情時候還要低
夠低了吧
現在36000點
他比疫情時候還要低
超低
比疫情時候還要低
然後
也有分點買不少的
唉唉唉唉
這都是免費的喔
免費的
啊這個我們訂閱PP的人也都知道啦
也都知道那個關鍵分點
有在買
喔 有有有 有一檔
各位看一下 這裡
來 我來看一下 這個叫美綠啦
喔美綠
喔 身為人員 身為人員不會
不會講的 身為人員不要這樣子那個
賠太多了啦
賠太多了 我講的是美綠
那各位你看一下美綠啦齁
美綠呢 疫情的時候呢是
2020年 它是114塊
夠低了吧
114很低囉
然後呢他有個分點叫元大文英新安
那這分點呢
這個還有台中分點齁
這個反正元大文英新安呢
他在低點的時候呢就去買美律
那時候最低是114
齁這個分點很厲害啦齁這個
他還有更厲害的
他以前呢好像2017年的時候
2017年呢每次法書會前一天他都買
齁每次法書會前天都買
然後呢 法座位都噴出
那時候都是他
都他
247 其實也還好各位 可憐還好你現在就是沒噴而已 但 至少每年配期填期都有 好不好可憐還好這個今年齁 今年沒跟AI扯上邊的都沒有噴
然後美綠呢 他也是沒有扯上邊
所以呢 他的位置還很低
那時候呢
114塊 文心心安吃蠻多的嘛 對不對
他好吃 反正他每次低點都會吃啦
然後最近各位看起來
他每次低點都有吃喔 上次低點在這邊大吃
這個點 吃了嘛 噴一段
然後這個急殺低點他也會吃
反正低點他都會去吃啊
齁 這種急殺的低點都會看到他
齁 急殺低點都會看到他 然後他也不是不會賣喔
這個反彈的高點他會賣
然後最近的一個低點 他買的超多
有沒有看到
最近的 欸
紀念品送有些有錢 真的喔 這麼好
喔
最近的低點他買超多
那不只他一個分點買
他有另外一個分點買 因為他庫長股實質
喔 那這個位置真的
比疫情還便宜
喔 現在87塊
喔 不能再低了 好不好
不能 欸 欸 欸 欸 欸 不能再低了
搞不好會更低啦 我沒有辦法保證不能再低
只是他這個價格很低了
87塊
沒有錯啊 真的很低
然後目前殖利率4.6%
最近呢他實施庫廠股
那庫廠股實施呢
有沒有認真買
各位看一下
我們看區間買超
買超第一名是元大文藝行安
買的超認真
那我們來超市 欸欸欸各位看一下
他10庫廠股錢他有買欸
欸這是怎樣
10庫廠股錢還有買
然後這個還是庫廠股
這代表說怎麼樣
代表說
除了公司派10庫廠股以外
還有跟公司派同分點的
呃公司的
呃親朋好友
喔
他們也也買
也也提早買
欸 也買在最低價
77.5
比疫情還低
也十字庫長股嘛
我們對十字庫長股在低檔的股票我們都表示尊重跟歡迎我覺得都不錯嘛因為我現在跟你講什麼很高的股票
現在跟你講
你敢買好不好
聯亞你敢買對不對
好不好敢買嗎
不敢買嘛對不對
這種股票太恐怖了
隨時來一根
因為這個很多高檔股票就隨時來一根滑通
你敢買隨時來一根對不對
那個ABF 你敢買
隨時來一根 對不對
隨時來一根
那 你就這個巴黎你買什麼
隨時來一根 你也不曉得他到底什麼時候要來一根
對不對 就怕怕的嘛 對不對
然後呢 至少這個是
低的嘛 我跟你講低的 我至少
我比較安全啊
我比較安全
為什麼 啊 就像經濟一樣啊
經濟你80、90買的
那你套牢 套牢是要領袭嘛
對不對 啊美律
美律人家現在雖然
營收是不怎麼樣 唉唷
營收也沒不怎麼樣欸 營收歪歪也正了欸
對不對
然後配息呢 我們看一下配息
配息也還不錯啦 對不對
今年配比較少而已啊
以往去年還配7塊欸 今年至少配個4塊
對不對 配個4塊87塊
配型也不錯啊
對不對 配型也不錯啊
美麗用可轉載不行啊
美麗用可轉載 我看一下
欸
欸好像可以喔 我想一下
好像可以欸
我看一下我看一下
我看一下美麗用可轉載行不行
可轉載好像也不錯喔
好 欸 可以可以可以
這美麗可轉載可以可以
可以
喔可是
有可能歸零高啦
說真的有可能歸零高
因為他假如他現在才67啊
喔他假如沒有歸零高的話
喔這個會翻翻多倍的
這個好像也可以喔這個
大概有14倍的槓桿好像可以喔
好像可以賭看看喔
可轉代用CBS的話用CBS啊
那你單純買可轉載也ok啦
頂多賠個3塊
頂多賠3塊而已
欸!現在可轉載
蠻不錯的餒
各位
有一檔可轉載我們
我們那個
關心很久的好不好
各位有沒有看到我們關心很久的可轉載
叫左燈
欸我們那個
趙姍姍打電話餒
打電話問候財務長餒
問候發言人我們趙姍姍打
我們的那個group
喔我們的那個
我們的
discord群
我們打電話就是關心他啦
關心他
就是說
關心這家公司嘛
因為總是
因為他KY啦
他被永冠所害
因為永冠有KY
他也有KY
所以我們又照三餐
欸不是照三餐
我們就
這個
偶爾就打電話去
關心他
說你左登山
你剩5.29億
然後你發7億
齁
我們都知道
你有左燈的那個
那個呃
城堡
齁
我們知道你有左燈城堡
欸各位看一下左燈城堡
齁
但是呢
我們是
你重要的
股東
兼債權人
我們不希望你走上了
永貫的
這個
後路
喔 步上永貫的後塵
喔 不是
不希望你步上永貫的後塵
我們希望你要
提早面對
萬一
你可轉載太多人賣回的狀況
喔 希望你
提早要
好好的因應這個
可轉載即將要賣回
喔
我希望它好好因應嘛
對不對 沒有錯啊
我們非常關心 我們買了很關心
欸各位你看一下
他這樣子欸
他現在21%欸
你知道21%什麼概念
你現在買到了7月11號
他沒有倒的話
他就得給你101塊
你現在花96塊給你101塊
所以看起來
看起來這個趴住看起來好像很危險好像要倒了齁
但是呢他今天已經
正式公告了好不好
各位佐登呢 在我們團隊的努力之下團隊的努力之下佐登呢 他迎來了
各位有沒有看到這個東西
可轉載續命招 借薪還救
掌聲鼓勵鼓勵 齁 來來
佐登KY董事會決議發行中華民國境內
第四次有擔保轉換載
喔 有單保轉換站 有沒有看到 有單保喔
欸這個是決議發行的 啊有單保
人家單保銀行都找好了
你懂的是嗎
人家單保的銀行都找好了
喔 來來來
我找給 找給各位看喔
公開資訊觀測站
喔 來來來
這邊
來
我應該結張圖啦
有沒有
發言人
就是我們
每次打電話找他的
發言人電話有沒有 有沒有 有有有有
齁
這個我們每次找他的
就找發言人
人還蠻好的 齁 人蠻好的
齁
佐登山
呵呵
他這個
償還 穆德價款用途運用計畫
償還中華民國境內第三次無擔保轉公司債
持有人執行賣予權手機制
有看到沒有?
喔 唉唷
長長今天說左生三變無擔保
沒問題啊 欸
現在人20%有擔保呢
看到沒有 直立20%呢
你現在要賣96塊
來
過了三個月101收欸
有沒有看到
喔有沒有看到這種東西啊
你現在你去買一檔股票
來來來
你現在你隨便買來
你現在告訴我哪一檔股票
來我們來來成交價
來
各位
我現在找96塊的來來來
找這幾檔
來這幾檔
來你現在這幾檔你跟我講
欸小哥這幾檔
三個月後
101收 保證101收
這幾檔
誰敢給我保證沒有人敢給我保證 對不對 沒有人保證後佐登已經怎麼樣 他發重訊了欸這發重訊再出事的話
他都找到
他都要發第四次有擔保了
然後都怎麼樣
喔
發行保證人都找到了
台灣土地銀行
土地銀行欸
這不是阿薩布魯的銀行欸
英航欸 台灣也沒什麼阿薩布魯銀行啦
對不對
第四次發不出來找土地銀行算帳
應該是發得出來吧
再發不出來 可轉載不要玩了
可轉載不要玩了 連借金環就
都出事 那就不要玩了
所以呢
這個看起來喔
應該沒什麼問題吧
看起來應該沒什麼問題
齁這個可轉載齁看起來應該沒問題
齁啊這個齁
這個告訴你怎樣
你現在買
你現在買齁
然後
這可轉載是這樣子的啊
就是
7..2026年7月11號101首
就這樣
齁 你在賣回日那一天你就可以時日賣回全了
他就得給你錢
齁他不給你錢
他就要
應該不會不給你錢啦
我覺得他都已經
都已經發行第四次
而且都已經找到擔保銀行了
我覺得應該沒有問題
把債務延後
後面會不會出事我不知道
我不知道
但這一次我覺得是
安全過關了
小哥美綠左增山是不是套很多
欸你想太多了
這個不叫套好不好
那你為什麼不說我經濟套很多
喔經濟套好多
經濟套很大
左燈還不算買得多欸
我買很多的齁
我買很多的最近
噴出了
不要講是誰
賣回日要申請嘛
賣回日要申請
好
好啦
我們再回來啦
再回來講美律啦
再回來講美律
這美律這個齁
不是套很多啦
美律這個位置是因為
他的關鍵分點
買這麼多
那麼這堂課就是要講怎麼樣
就講關鍵分 神秘分點
建倉的清單嘛這神秘分點這樣子建倉 建那麼多那他有可能 有可能怎麼樣 有可能後面有機會像經濟一樣 我不曉得有沒有機會像經濟啦
假如有機會像經濟就很好了
內置主力分點可以 在外置分點買賣 可以啊 可以啊
101-96等於是有這麼高嗎
首先101-96等於5
好,101.9等於5
其次,他只剩三個月好不好
各位,只剩三個月
要漲5%
還不止5%
所以你說他有沒有21.6%
你懂我意思嗎?這叫,那個職業叫做那個
那個叫做到期年化職利率
年化職利率
如果你從關鍵分點就開始買
高檔一路買下來
現在肯定套產了
啊
你到底在講哪一段
喔你說從這裡喔
好啦從這裡套是套產了
但沒有啊你從這裡買你這裡會賣掉啊
你從這裡買這裡不是會賣掉
對不對
然後再疊下來 人家在這裡買比較多啊
所以你是到底在講哪一段
好啦好啦 沒關係啦 你假如覺得會套就會套
我只是在跟你講說
美律這個D檔買很多 然後殖利率也不錯
好不好
殖利率也不錯
你
你不想當駕駛仔的
應該這樣講說
這個殖利率不錯 至少你買齁
抱一段時間呢 比較不會擔心
好 那
但是講這些齁
大家還是不喜歡的
好不好 大家 很多人還是不喜歡
他就喜歡怎麼樣
他就喜歡買漲停漲停漲停再漲停
好不好
你喜歡買這種漲停漲停漲停再漲停的
你喜歡玩這種刺激的齁
我建議你做什麼事啊
我建議你去看
酬馬好的標的
好不好有沒有看到
酬馬好標的
那酬馬好很多漲停嘛
酬馬好
台勝各一家和聲堂經濟漲停
酬馬好以勝油田和聲堂
長新大長 經濟漲停
籌碼好 和聲堂 毫米 油田 金色 以順漲停
籌碼好很多漲停
那這個籌碼好怎麼選的喔
籌碼好其實每天喔 只會選10檔
那每天只有10檔而已
每天呢我們只是把那個籌碼好的標的齁
我們找籌碼...呦
昨天剛好都漲停
不能這樣
我們不能找那個前一天都漲停了
我們要找那個前一天
還有一些沒有掌...籌碼好也很容易漲停啦
因為他籌碼好又...又延上軌真的很容易漲停
齁來來來...欸這邊...
這個籌碼好的...喔這邊就沒有全部都漲停
齁這邊有很多籌碼好標的
那籌碼好的就是他的籌碼...
主一到主十這裡籌碼是好的
齁籌碼是好的...然後那上通斜率呢是蠻標的
美綠買兩年了 現在陳百在一
好可憐
但是這個位置比較漂亮啦
我們以前也不想跟你講美綠啊
我也不可能在這裡跟你講美綠嘛
關鍵大賣跟你講美綠幹嘛
在大買的時候跟你講嘛 對不對
大買的時候要講一下
去買去
對啊 大買的時候要跟你講
大買的時候跟你講
然後再跟各位講
你要比較比較標的股票齁
你可以去找那個籌碼好的標的
喔籌碼好的標的每天就死打
齁那你假如想在盤中的去猜
今天
這個有機會籌碼好的標的
然後也可以
齁你可以用一些參數
就可以去找
齁例如說你去找說那個
呃我們標股有的參數齁
標課這個參數你可以自己選啦
你看我是找成交量大於5
大於300 掌跌5大於5 上回血率大於1 位階大於5
欸位階可以高一點
我可以位階大於8
均量比 均量比好像太高了 均量比大於2就好
主5 主10 主20都大於0
儲存
那儲存之後呢 我們再用月線協率排序
你要記得喔你要去找那個月線協力排序比較低的比較低的有的是鋼標再講一次喔比較低的是剛標的那假如是比較高的就是標很久了
合生糖
標很久
然後剛標的是這個
漢與波
剛起來了還沒標
愛華
哇這個剛起來
全球
萬國通
又通
唉唷 萬國兜今天被盜貨
敬果 等下我把它套用一下
齁
就是我們可以去找那個
這個 唉唷
看起來 預言協律 金城科不錯
喔 今天第一個
漢與波
愛華 喔 這種都是剛起來的
喔 剛起來的
你也可以找這種剛起來的
然後去去找
去找類似好的標的
喔好的標的齁
所以各位可以
可以這樣子找
齁 那今天要找漲停的就是這樣
你要找比較會動的齁
啊這些都比較會動
你找標股啊 這幾個都比較會動
這幾個都會動啦
我以為你明天繼續看
你明天把我的
那個
直播再拿回來看
看這幾個會不會動
這幾個
對啊 這幾個盤中你可以這樣找啊
那這幾個他就有經過篩選了
主力 五日 十日
啊這三點你都可以自己塞啊
小哥你大於0我不要
我要大於3
可以啊
就隨便你
大於1我不要我要大於3可以
齁
可以
儲存
齁就變比較少
齁那是籌碼更好
齁 延通
哇
勵志
標的
齁你可以這樣找大力光
欸大力光我有
來我有大力光
喔 本益比最低的CPO
本益比最低的CPO
就這樣啊
你要找標股你可以這樣找嗎
這種就我在動了
這肯定大波
喔
肯定大波股
好不好
這幾個各位可以拍起來
一定大波的啦
因為選一選也沒幾檔
就這幾檔
肯定大波股
喔
好
手機版的呢
手機版的各位呢你可以找
這個標封向上鼓
標封向上鼓欸盤中也可以找啊等一下我先desk印一下我連到我的手機板
連到我的手機給你看
手機板也可以拉
他也可以找到類似的股票
好
來
這是我手機版的畫面
手機的畫面給各位看
唉唷 處置成績
當沖標股
標封向上股
這裡
你要找股票可以從這裡找
這都是比較標的股票 強勢股
喔 可以看走勢
喔 盤中也可以這樣找
喔 這邊有很多
標的股票啦
標的股票
喔 那你可以找那個
月限協率不要太高的
因為月限率不要太高的呢 他有的都是剛開始標
剛開始標的喔
院協力很陡的喔 都是標一段時間的
標一段時間你的風險比較大嘛
你看和聲堂大量環宇
欸環宇我是今天
那個環宇今天就比較偏空了
因為
我今天在盤中我就做了一個配
盤中呢這個有聽到我們discord都有講到
我今天在
那個環宇快要漲停的時候 我做了一個配
叫做環波配
我空了環宇買菠蘿威
各位的你去看一下我菠蘿威買在1130
我今天菠蘿威買1130
環宇空在快漲停
環波配
喔因為今天菠蘿威跌下來這個點我覺得還不錯
那今天跌下來在這裡啊
我是買到1130我沒有買到最低啦
我買到1130我沒有買到1110
我買到1130
喔
我是在做一個1130
然後
環雨空在漲停附近
那環雨明天被關了那又留一個上影線我覺得明天應該走勢比較弱我環宇大概是空在空在漲停附近
我們算638
算640好了
比較好算
640 1130
比例大概是1比2
就空環宇兩張然後
買波羅位一張
環波配
我的那個盤中的配
我覺得我蠻喜歡我超愛做雙刀
雙刀真的很好玩
就是買A空B
像我昨天買景碩空星星
我在禮拜天的高雄農場上課
我就有講了 我說禮拜一我要
買景碩空星星
我要這麼做
好 今天在盤中呢 我們跟那個盤中的
那個discord學友 我有講 我跟他說
我說這個點 我覺得
環宇跟波羅威這點實在太美了
我就空環宇買波羅威
喔 那目前為止是雙賺啦
因為環雨大概空在640附近嘛
那這裡就跌到620了 就賺了快20塊
那波羅位是賺了70塊
你自己看一下 你自己看這時間啊
這個時間齁 這個10點21分
那對應的是環雨的這個位置 差不多吧
10點21分是在那個快要漲停附近
你懂我意思嗎 所以這個環波配齁 環波配而且
懷宇跟波羅威的相關係數非常高
各位我們來看一下懷宇跟波羅威的相關係數
這一招真的很好用喔
這一招呢叫做
各位你自己看 你自己看
懷宇跟波羅威長的其實很像
喔懷宇跟波羅威長的很像
喔那這一招呢就是我們
這個在處置戰法裡面的經典啦
喔那處置戰法呢
這招為什麼我會這麼用喔
其實是因為我用了處置神器
好 那處置戰法呢 我們今天來講一下
處置戰法我們要上了最後一堂線上體驗課
前面已經上了三堂了
三堂呢 有很多人都重複報名
上了第一堂 再上第二堂 再上第三堂
上的內容是類似的 但是案例都不一樣
為什麼 因為我每個禮拜都做嘛 我每天都做
我是每天做 每個禮拜都做
所以呢 這個做處置呢 做得非常有經驗
做處置很有經驗
那我們每個禮拜呢 都會有
都會有那個 痾 新的案例
然後像我這禮拜我就告訴你
我就是
空還雨
買菠蘿威
空高麗
買雙紅
我都跟你講了喔
這個我跟妳講事實上我是有危險的
明天那些主力要來告我
告我懷疑我就完了
喔那沒關係我買菠蘿威保護一下
喔然後那個
雙紅跟高麗
空高麗買雙紅
空
星星買景碩
喔不過
空心滿緊錯我今天已經有解掉一些了
我已經有解掉一些了
好啊這個
這個雙刀齁
這個雙刀我們
體驗課呢
會
教你
要怎麼做
因為這個
雙刀
非常值得做
各位呢
趕緊報名好不好
這個是限量的
有限的
喔
你要從華語去找就看得到菠蘿威
從華語去找看菠蘿威
喔 華語菠蘿威
那很值得做啦
我今天
這盤中我就傳那個啦
傳給我的
群組看
喔
盤中我有傳
這個
就很好
好
那這個
處置日報呢會告訴你
明天呢有哪些
股票會被關
然後那條件是什麼
那這個在處置神器裡面
處置神器裡面有處置日報
那這個我是覺得很值得一做啦
處置真的很好玩
很好玩
好 那到統計功能 這個我們明天呢 在 禮拜四呢
我們在那個
組織課呢 在海王跟各位講
好 那我們今天 欸 今天
請各位加一加這個Q塊塊
忘了加了
好 歡迎各位加一下這個討論群
加一下討論群啊
掃碼加一下
密碼四個八
好 各位呢 先加一下這個討論群啊密碼四個八好
環宇波羅威
各位啊 環宇波羅威給你看一下
等一下
等一下看一下是雙刀
環宇第一個就波羅威啊
今天盤中偏差率更高
盤中偏差率更高
盤中的偏差率更高
我是覺得波羅威
我覺得他以後的走勢
有機會比環宇來得強
好不好
那今天這個環宇配波羅威
我覺得配得非常好
因為盤中已經獲利了
就是
黃羽跟薄羅衛已經
已經賺到了
高麗雙紅
看看啦 我希望雙紅上去啦
我覺得雙紅有點弱
那我希望那個
這些阻力齁 在高麗被關的時候
可以來關照一下雙紅啦
好不好 欸
雙紅是有波段權證的餒
各位
雙紅有波段權證餒
給你看一下
我們統計天數拉長一點
欸 雙龍那麼順重欸
南屯哥勒
南屯哥目前賠兩千萬欸
看到沒有
你現在買是比大盤上還便宜欸
南屯哥賠兩千萬
台中哥呢
華麗永昌台中
台中哥呢賠多少 各位看一下
賠一千八
群毅忠利哥這不是我
這不是我
這跟你講不是我
群毅忠利哥賠多少
我不會買全鎮啦
我買全鎮幹嘛
我買期貨就好了
買全鎮幹嘛
買全鎮浪費時間價值幹嘛
你知道嗎
我幹嘛浪費時間價值啊
對不對
我買期貨就好
期貨造勢那麼好
所以我不會買全鎮
各位你也不要買全鎮
大陸有錢
大陸可以這樣子浪費時間價值
我們不行
好不好
喔 那各位啊
南屯哥跟華南永昌台中
各位不要忘記了
喔 不要忘記了華泰喔 各位 華泰華南永昌台中 唉唷 還賠錢藍屯哥賺錢了 好不好藍屯哥賺2500萬了
藍屯哥賺2500萬
喔
然後呢 各位呢 你再看一下那個
雙紅的
這個 可轉載
欸 無丹寶 唯買132是怎樣啊
有沒有看到
無單寶唯買132
市值87
這買殼轉載的人
他在抵什麼我不知道欸
欸無單寶欸
那有單寶欸
你買132
然後還沒有單寶
然後市值才87
你到底圖的是什麼東西
我叫權政小哥所以我懂權政
我知道權政不能這樣玩
但這些大戶我就不曉得他為什麼全證這樣玩
我就不曉得他為什麼要這樣子玩
他為什麼要買全證在那邊浪費時間價值
對不對 這種股票你怎麼可以把全證在那邊
在那邊等呢
對不對 他這個大盤子在那邊等嘛
那我跟各位講
我告訴高麗的主力好不好
這個高麗的主力
你可以休息了
喔 你讓高麗休息吧
因為他短線
第一個短線長得有點多嘛
第二個
你現在買要20分鐘
你要入金
對不對 多麻煩
喔 啊不如現在有一檔
不用入金的
門入金的喔 叫雙紅 門入金
喔 啊 都散熱
好 都散熱
喔 都散熱
喔 啊 然後怎麼樣
然後呢 各位看一下
可轉載 有人在誤
可轉載132
市值87
這個可轉載超級溢價
你不用擔心可轉載有人來套利
沒辦法套啦 沒辦法套
可轉載人高價賣掉而已 怎麼套
這裡沒有人套利
這裡沒有可轉載賣亞
從可轉載的角度來看 這檔股票非常漂亮
這檔股票很漂亮
所以你要做雙刀 啊這種最適合啊 你看什麼
對不對 高麗配雙紅
我都跟你講 我的牌都跟你講
我不曉得明天長怎樣啊 對不對我這樣跟你講 我是有風險明天雙紅跌停 高麗漲停我的酸民從留言會流一千折出來 你知道嗎
留言是流一千折出來 小哥細喝
空什麼高麗 買什麼雙紅 對不對
我們提早講都是有風險的 你懂嗎
提早講都是有風險
那我們還是跟你講
我是 我的組合都跟你講了
其實我們常常提早跟學人講
阿就在折嘛 我至少做雙刀嘛
我跟你講我雙刀至少
我跟你講那個
雖然有風險 但是我還是得跟你講
因為
你看久了你就會相信我嘛
我說提早跟你講 就像經濟也提早跟你講啊
他跌了也會跟你講說 我還有啊
我又不是沒有 對不對
我賠也賠比你多啊
對不對
賠也賠比你多啊
對,所以我都可以提早跟你講
後面怎麼樣我不知道
但是我就很誠實的可以告訴你這樣
好,各位可以加一下
這個我們的不定時會在裡面聊一天
盤中絕對不會,我盤中我也不會在裡面代單
好不好
你盤中你有遇到代單的都是詐騙
來再跟各位講一次,你盤中遇到代單的
真的
那都是詐騙喔
那個不是我喔
那個不是我
不要再來問了
盤中一對來問
齁來
盤中有沒有看到
當衝參考
做多我剛才贏9點2分
那滑鼠一直7一直7一直7
9點2分這是我們
很激烈的時候
滑鼠一直按一直按
按不停
我還有時間打字9點2分
當衝參考做多
做什麼話科啦做多
對不對 我怎麼可能做多啦
盤中還跟你講說我要做多 我的法屬伺子比較沒力
大家說做多
然後 喔 這個 望紅亮燈啦
恭喜各位賺錢 大家自信下車
我哈贏
喔 我第一看這等於我的群組喔
現在超多的 然後這些都是拖
這些全部都拖
都是拖 好不好
什麼叫拖 各位你知道嗎
都拖 東西拖
然後這些人齁 你在每個社群 你看到的
名字都不一樣 啊
講話都一樣
那都是同一台電腦 一台電腦就一個
你就一人分是
一人分是
那個300個人
一人分是300個人
1135個社群裡面
搞不好只有5個是真的
其中1130個
有700個是殭屍
300個是這個負責講話的拖
然後這些拖呢都長得很奇怪
什麼達叔這都已經
往生了拜登
拜登都吃呆了
小蘭 琪琪
看起來都網美
都假欸
那都假的
好不好
我盤中沒有空帶單啊好不好
不要再來問的一堆人來問小哥這是你嗎
我那好可憐
那好可憐我期間
對不對按
按滑鼠都按到沒力了還來跟你
還跟你帶單
還跟你虛寒問暖
然後每次都很難問
欸小哥
這是你嗎你私訊我了
你看各位你看一下
這邊喔
你看我這大頭貼寫什麼
各位你看一下 我看一下大頭貼
來來來
給各位看
我的大頭貼啊
喔這裡
大頭貼
任名藍鉤鉤 我跟小秘書沒空私訊你
然後呢 就
拿一個私訊的跟我講 小哥這個是你嗎
我都我的大頭天都跟你講我沒空失去你了
那失去你的都是詐騙
那是你都詐騙嘛對不對
我們現在詐騙太多了
喔很多喔好
好啦
那個我們今天呢還有一個世紀投資寶這個是
最後一週了最後一週了齁
然後呢我們夠客會想每月更新實戰影片
一支
4月份
3月份有分享的
4月份以後也會分享
那感謝葉子捐子余還有欽倚的推薦
我在
那個兩天
在上禮拜五有去
吳淡如那邊
吳淡如最新的Pockets也有我
各位有空也可以去聽一下
那這個直播限定快展折扣券呢
是西人0414
可以再折700元
使用期限是4月16號
各位有興趣的也可以購客
好
希望哪一天抽錢的事情各位呢你可以在presspress搜尋全球的4的市益投資法好啦 那各位 小秘書也不會失聚你 好不好這 聚於海 也不會失聚你
也不會失聚你
好 那我們上次中獎名單齁
欸 儲治股是天上掉下來的禮物
了解儲治股特技關係 會想找滿一點 儲治結束前的阿賴
只要找到規律 反而比一般正常股更好入手
股價也比大主便宜
感謝小哥每週的無私分享
真的啦 儲治股滿好玩的 有興趣可以玩
感謝小哥噴點
創新高拉回找買點
記憶體秋天的股票謝謝
記憶體秋天啊
啊昨天
南亞科講得很好對不對
賺得很多
賺8塊嘛
今天股價看起來好像跌0.8
欸好像賺0.8塊
哈哈
那沒辦法啊
籌碼就比較爛
啊這個籌碼爛喔
需要一段時間的沉澱
喔那沉澱久了
後面才有機會再上去
啊現在要沉澱一段時間
要沉澱一段時間
那我沒有說南亞科不會創新高
沒有 他不見得不會創新高
但是要一段時間
他要把這段籌碼化解一下
化解一下
那京區我們之前有說他處置癌嘛
他以前處置癌啊 有沒有一堆注意 一堆注意嘛
最近癌症好了 為什麼
最近這邊都沒有注意了 為什麼沒有注意
因為他用時間換取了空間
他這邊注意呢 有很多條件喔 各位有沒有看到
他有的條件怎麼樣
他有條件喔 有條件長多了
有條件是你短線呢 短線長很多
然後他 他花了很長一段時間
這個時間換取了空間 最近注意呢
變少了
喔 變少了 今天好不容易出現第一款
他至少第六款沒了
第六款沒了
所以我覺得它就比較好一點
比較好一點
金具已經轉好了啦
轉好了
然後呢
來來來
最後呢我們有可轉載的策略高階班
那這個我們有教那個
動態避險
我最喜歡玩的就是
動態避險加雙刀
這兩個齁
好好的教我兒子
好好的玩這兩個
因為動態避險不會賠我現在教各位一個方法我在 科長上也有教我們找了一個標的 你買可轉載可轉載擺就不會賠了 為什麼
因為我們買的可轉載
我們買這一檔啊
這請問他撩 撩也撩沒什麼
這邊撩有什麼 我不知道
這賣回家有修正過了 實際上是103
喔 你現在買104啊
4月27號那一天 你可以用103叫他收回
可以用103讓他收回
所以你現在買103 你現在買104 頂多賠一塊啦
頂多賠一塊 但是現在的市值102喔
現在市值已經102了 102.4了
他拉一根漲停 他就跟著漲
所以陳德七喔 你現在買 明天陳德漲停
明天成德漲停
他的可轉載呢 就會到110
明天成德跌停
你也不用怕 為什麼 因為
4月27號那一天
你可以跟他講說 欸103
103請我好不來算啊
103喔 不是102
不是100喔 是103喔
所以你買這種
不用怎麼輸
你還可以玩動態欸
啊動態就是
欸有空來上課啦
我會再教你
動態就是
漲也賺 跌也賺 叫東泰
喔 啊陳德基可以這樣玩 啊最近還有一檔
喔 我
昨天有call 立生人員2
現在市值95
可轉載99
102收
明年5月2號
好 明年5月2號102收
除非要倒
沒有倒的話 你現在買可轉載
沒有倒的話 我再跟哥講前提喔 沒有倒的話
他也不是立生人員KY 沒有 沒有KY 連KY都沒有
小哥有收到法院傳票 沒有啦 茂名 沒有
還發傳票給我 拜託欸 那麼
嘿
全世界都 全台灣都知道那有茂名
茂名一種欸 那還要發給我
那被騙的人
被騙的人還要發我傳票 我有 我就頭就痛了
而且我們有報案過
我們有報案 發傳媒體都報案過
我不只報案 還每次在臉書上面公告
我們都有發公告那不是我 不是我 不是我被騙的是你笨 是你笨 是你笨喔 是你笨 是你每次都不好好想 是你笨喔 不是我 不是我 不是我
喔 跟各位講 喔 是你貪 是你笨
盤中不會有給你代單的 代單都是想騙你的錢 好不好
你看這立生人員2
他已經95了 而且跳功一次線出現了
今天走勢比較弱啦
啊這個
假如再一次挑一支線他就連動了
他假如沒有連動至少102收啊
有沒有看到
至少102收
包案可以免收傳票我不知道啦
至少目前為止我沒有收傳票
沒有 然後我們
再跟各位講喔 其實國家有在做事
國家有在做事 我都有收到這種
喔 數位發展部 來給各位看一下
喔
來 這裡啊
來給各位看一下 數位發展部來
我就不要把那個
信貼出來
數位發展部 呃數位發展部代理名人授權書 有沒有看到
我現在是那個
國家
國家數位發展部
認證的名人
呵呵呵 名人
好
感謝您近日提供數位發展部反詐騙
我是反詐騙工作小組
的那個
夥伴
並加入數位發展部公眾人物反詐
通報專用郵箱
啊然後呢
然後只要
只要有人仿冒我
啊你們有去檢舉
他就會寄封信來
啊跟我確認說
跟我確認說
啊真的 這個真的是詐騙嗎
我說他真的是詐騙
啊我就回信啦 我就回信
回信說
他真的詐騙
那回信真的詐騙
就好啦
我來看一下
那個最新的信
我找一下
數位發展
欸
這邊
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕